[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى الاخبار الساعه من العربيه
وهذه عناوين
واشنطن تستنفر كافه اجهزتها للوصول الى
حطام المسيره في البحر الاسود بعد اعلان
موسكو البحث عن
بعد السجناء الرجال موسكو تجدد سجنات
للحرب في جبهات القتال شرق اوكرانيا
رغم تعهداتها السابقه طالبان اكثر من 20
جماعه مسلحه في افغانستان نفذت هجمات في
دول العدل
وبعد مظاهرات مستمره رئيس الاسرائيلي يحذر
من حرب اهليه بسبب خطه الحكومه لاحكام
يدها على القطنه
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تعليق وزير الدفاع الامريكي على
تحطم المسيره الامريكيه في البحر الاسود
حيث قال ان الطيران العسكري الامريكي
سيواصل التحليق في اطار القانون الدولي
اصل اكد ان على روسيا تشغيل مقاتلتها
بطريقه احترافيه وامنه
[موسيقى]
امريكيه كانت تقوم بمهمه عاديه في المجال
الجوي الدولي وحدث اصطدام مع مقاتله روسيه
هذا يعد حلقه متجدده من افعال الطيارين
الروس المتهوره في المجال الجوي الدولي
اجره اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظير الروسي وكررت
انه من المهم ان تكون القوه العظمى مثالا
للشفافيه والتواصل الولايات المتحده
ستواصل التحليق في اطار القانون الدولي
ومن مهام روسيا ان تشغل مقاتلاتها بطريقه
احترافيه وامنه في المجال الجوي الدولي
في المقابل اكد مديره الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه
ان الولايات المتحده تقوم بعمليات استطلاع
نشطه في منطقه البحر الاسود باستخدام
وسائل تكنولوجيه مختلفه وقال ان
الامريكيين يستخدمون بنشاط كبير جميع
الوسائل خصوصا الاستطلاع البصري
والاستطلاع اللاسلكي وقال سكرتيرو مجلس
الامن الروسي ان موسكو تحاول ايضا العثور
على حطام المسيره الامريكيه التي سقطت امس
في البحر الاسود
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه اعلن بدا تحقيق
في حادث الموجه بين مسيره الامريكيه
ومقاتله الروسيه فوق البحر الاسود وقال
بلانك المواجهه امر متهور وغير امن قبل
ذلك قال متحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الحادثه من المحتمل ان تكون عملا غير
مقصود وقع بسبب عدم كفاءه الطيارين الروس
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه
ان الولايات المتحده كانت تتجاهل حقيقه ان
روسيا قد انشات مجانا جويا فوق البحر
الاسود واضاف ان روسيا اسست حدود الرحلات
الجويه في المنطقه بعد بدء الحمله
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا وهي الحقيقه
التي تدركها الولايات المتحده جيدا
احتكاك روسي امريكي خطير مقاتله روسيه
مقابل مسيره امريكيه في تفاصيل الحادثه
التي وصفت بالخطيره
اصطدمت مقاتله روسيه من طراز سوخويت وانت
7 بطائره امريكيه مسيره من طراز ام كيو 9
ريبر وقالت واشنطن ان قواتها اضطرت الى
اسقاط مسيره في البحر الاسود اما موسكو
فتقول ان الحادثه وقعت بالقرب من جزيره
القرم لكن لماذا وجدت مسيره امريكيه
بطريقه استفزت روسيا فوق البحر الاسود
المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون يقولون ان
الطائره المسيره كانت تقوم بعمليات
روتينيه في المجال الجوي الدولي اما
البنتاغون فاستنكر الحادثه واتهم
المقاتلات الروسيه بالقاء الوقود امام
المسيرات الامريكيه الا انه رفض الافصاح
عما اذا كانت مسيره مسلحه ام لا
المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها بينما للروس
روايه اخرى فهم ينظرون للحادث باعتباره
استفزازا موسكو نفتعمدها اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه وقالت ان ام كيو 9 ريبر تحطمت
بعد ارتطامها بسطح البحر الاسود لاسباب
تعود لفقدانها الارتفاع بعد قيامها
بمناوره حاده واثناء تحليقها اضفت اجهزه
تعريفها في انتهاك لمنطقه الحظر الجوي ما
دفع مقاتلتين روسيتين الاعتراضها الا
انهما لم تسقطاها ولم تقترب منها بشكل
خطير مستبعدين رغبه موسكو بالمواجهه مع
واشنطن حتى الان للولايات المتحده ولا
روسيا تمكنتا من استعاده حطام المسيره
الامريكيه الا ان هذا التصعيد الاخير حذر
منه مسؤول البلدين خاصه وانه اول مواجهه
مباشره بين الطرفين منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا روان حمزه العربيه
وتابع تفاصيل من واشنطن مع زميل بيرهان
مهلا بك
الى اي مدى تخشى الولايات المتحده من سقوط
هذه الطائره في قبضه القوات الروسيه مع
انها تتحدث اكثر من مره بانها قد قامت
بازاله ومسح جميع البيانات لدى هذه
الطريقه
ليس كثيرا اولا لان الامريكيين دمروا
البرامج الموجوده على هذه الطائره وهذه
المسيره سقطت في المياه الدوليه على عمق
الف متر وسوف يكون من الصعب على الروس ان
يصلوا الى حطام هذه الطائره وربما يصل
اليها حلفاء للامريكيين وهذا ما يعمل عليه
الامريكيون الان قبل ان يصل اليها الروس
بالاضافه الى هذا وذاك لا يعتبر
الامريكيون وقد تحدث الجنرال ميلي قبل
قليل الى جانب وزير الدفاع الامريكيه حول
هذا الموضوع وهم لا يعلقون اهميه على
مساله الحطام طيب اذا كانوا لا يعلقون
مساله على هذا الحطام لماذا كل هذا البحث
المطر سواء من قبل الروس او حتى الولايات
المتحده وهل هناك اساليب معينه تستخدمها
واشنطن في هذه المرحله للوصول الى
طائراتها وان كانت البيانات قد مسحته لك
على الاقل تحمل تقنيه امريكيه متقدمه
قبل قليل ان ليست هناك قوات بحريه امريكيه
موجوده في منطقه البحر الاسود ولكن قال
وزير الدفاع على امريكي والجري قبل قليل
ان هناك قوات حليفه موجوده في المنطقه
وتستطيع ان نتحدث هنا عنها بشكل خاص عن
رومانيا وبلغاريا وتستطيع ان نتحدث ايضا
عن تركيا وهي جميعها قادره على القيام
بعمليات البحث والوصول الى حطام هذه
الطائره كان هناك تخوف بالامس من ان تتطور
هذه الحادثه الى ازمه جديده في العلاقات
الامريكيه الروسيه ما بعد اوكرانيا من
خلال التصريحات التي صدرت هل هناك اجواء
تهدئه ام تصعيد في واشنطن
كان الكلام على الامريكي اليوم حازما
ولكنه كان من الواضح ان الامريكيين يريدون
ابقاء خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه مع الروس
وزير الدفاع على الامريكيه هو الذي بادر
للاتصال بزميله الروسي وتحدث اليه اليوم
الجيره الملي رئيس هيئه اركان المشتركه هو
ايضا سوف يتحدث الى نظيره الروسي
الامريكيون من الواضح انهم يريدون ابقاء
خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه بالاضافه الى ذلك
يريدون ويتعملون القول ان هذه المساله
ليست مساله عسكريه وليست مساله مواجهه ولا
تصعيد المساله هي مساله قانونيه في
معلومات خاصه بنا نستطيع القول ان هذه
المسيره كانت تطير على مسافه 75 ميل بحري
من جزيره القرب اي انها كانت في الاجواء
الدوليه وفوق مياه دوليه وبالتالي
الامريكيون يتمسكون بالمبدا الذي يقول انه
من حق قوات الامريكيه ان
تطير هذه الطائره في الاجواء الدوليه وهذا
ينطبق ايضا على الروس ولكنه لا تستطيع
روسيا بالمقابل برايي الامريكيين فرض
اجواء من عندها فقط لانها تقول ان هذه هي
الاجواء التابعه لنا وبالتالي ويريد
الامريكيون التاكيد على هذا وهذا ما اورده
ايضا في حديثه مع نظيره الروسي
تبحث الولايات المتحده بالقرب من جزيره
شبه جزيره القرم وهل ستستمر تلك العمليات
بحسب بيانات
بدون شك ان الامريكيين يريدون متابعه هذه
العمليات بقرب جزيره القرب لا يقولون بشكل
مباشر ان هذه الطائره كانت تقوم بعمليات
مسح للقوات الروسيه الموجوده على جزيره
القرم وبالتالي هم يحاولون التجسس لمصلحه
اوكرانيا ولكن اي ناظر لهذه المساله يفهم
انها الامريكيين يستعملون المجال الدولي
للتجسس على الروس ويحاولون مساعده
الاوكرانيين واليوم جدد وزير الدفاع على
امريكي كلام واضح من خلال مجموعه العمل
ومساعده اوكرانيا الى ان الامريكيين مع
خمسين دوله اخرى يقفون الى جانب اوكرانيا
ويعتبرون ان روسيا هي دوله معتديه ويجب ان
توقف هذا
الاعتداء على دوله اوكرانيا
من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
سؤال جديد في هذه الازمه هل دفعت حده
المعارك في اوكرانيا موسكو الى الاستعانه
بالايدي الناعمه تهمه ثقيله وجهتها صحيفه
البريطانيه الى روسيا بتوظيف النساء بشكل
مباشر في الحرب في اوكرانيا الصحيفه
البريطانيه ذكرت ان روسيا ترسل النساء
المدانات بتهم في السجون الروسيه الى
ساحات القتال في شرق اوكرانيا
التهمه لم توجه فقط من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني تقول صحيفه
بل ايضا من طرف منظمه خلف القضوان الروسيه
التي تدافع عن حقوق السجناء في روسيا
وبهذا الخصوص قالت رئيسه المنظمه اولغا ان
موسكو بدات في تجديد السجينات نهايه العام
الماضي وكان الجيش الاوكراني قد ذكر في
شهر فبراير الماضي ان روسيا اخرجت 50
مدانه من سجن في منطقه دونيتسك التي تسيطر
عليها موسكو وارسلتهن الى روسيا للتدريب
العسكري وفي سياق متصل اشاره الصحيفه
البريطانيه الا انه في ديسمبر الماضي قال
رئيس مجموعه باجلا
ان مجموعه من السجينات طلبنا ارسال هنا
الى اوكرانيا كممرضات او للعمل في مجال
الاتصالات العسكريه واضاف انه يجري العمل
على ذلك
المحلل السياسي سيد افقيني
تتساءل سانداي تايمز هل
خلطت موسكو من المقاتلين الرجال حتى يتم
الزج بسجينات في معارك اوكرانيا
تحيه لك والاساده المشاهدين انا لا اعتقد
ان هذه الفكره ومهما كان المبادر بها سواء
او ان هناك عدد من النواب من بعض المدن
الواقع في شرق روسيا بهذا الشعب ارسال
السجينات الى الجبهه انا لا اعتقد بان هذه
الفكره واقعيه
لانها اولا تتعارض مع
الامر المعروف للجميع ان السجين او
السجينه عاده ما حالتهم النفسيه يعني
بعيده عن ان تكون جيده او حتى معتدله هذا
اولا ثانيا المراه طبعا حتى اذا تم
تجنيدها وارسالها الى
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه يجب ان تسبق ذلك
فتره طويله من التدريب
وبالتالي لا اعتقد بان لهذه الفكره منطق
يعني اساس منطقي تماما
وليس من قبيل الصدفه بالمناسبه انه
بالنسبه للرجال السجناء رئيس شركه
صرح منذ اكثر من شهر بان عمليه تجديدهم
انتهت ولم يعد هناك يعني حاجه اليهم اعتقد
بان نفس الشيء ينطبق على النساء اللواتي
طبعا بحاجه كما قلت الى فتره طويله
لتدريب لكي يتم ارسالهما الى الجبهه
بالمناسبه
تحدث عن امكانيه استخدامهن كقناصه مثلا او
خبيرات في التفجير واعمال اخرى لا شك ان
يعني مثل هذه المهنه وهذا الاختصاص يتطلب
تدريبا طويلا قبل ان يكون من الممكن
استخدام العنصر النسائي
يتعلق بتصريحات التي ذكرت الصندايز بان
هناك بالفعل محاولات روسيه سواء كانت من
بقره او بعض القيادات العسكريه في استخدام
النسايه بان هناك محاوله للبحث عن نوعيات
معينه لاختصار
مده التدريب ولكن هناك مشكله هل يوجه
الجيش الروسي
مشكله في التجنيد نتحدث عن جيش روسي نتحدث
عن تجنيد الزابي نتحدث عن سجناء او سجينات
تمزج بهم في المعارك نتحدث عن ميليشيات
كما يجري مع فاجنر هل هناك اشكاليه فيما
يتعلق بعدد الجنود الروس في الجبل
الاوكرانيه
انا لا اعتقد بان هناك اي اشكاليه في هذا
المجال اولا لان عمليه التجديد وارسال
العناصر الجدد الى
اوكرانيا ما زالت مستمره وفقا
لتجديد او تعبئه الجزئيه التي اعلنت في
خريف من العام الماضي الان يقال ان عدد
اليك الذين يتواجدون اما في الجبهه او في
مواقع قريبه منها ويواصلون التدريب يكفي
تماما لتنفيذ المهام التي تنص عليها خطه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي انا لا اعتقد بان لمثل هذه
الشائعات والاقوال والتصريحات بشان
استخدام السجناء والسجينات اي اساس منطقي
لان حتى اذا تم
ارسالهم اولا لن يكون عددهم كبيرا والذي
يؤثر على سير العمليه العسكريه
وثانيا لان يعني عمليا ليه معنى
لارسالهم واستخدامهم لكونهم غير مدربين
حتى رغم القول كما تفضلت بانه يمكن اختصار
فتره التدريب وارسالهم الى الجبهه اعتقد
بان هناك
يكفي من الجنود او المجندين
مستعدين للقتال علما بان التطورات
الرئيسيه التي ينتظرها الجميع بفارغ الصبر
ربما سواء بالنسبه للهجوم الروسي او
بالنسبه للهجوم المضاده الاوكراني الان
هذه الفتره لم تحل بعد كما يبدو رغم ضراوه
المعارك مثلا حول مدينه بخموت من بوسكو
المحلل السياسي روسيا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
المشاركه في المعارك لا تقتصر على حمل
سلاح فحسب بل تشمل مهاما اخرى من بينها
التنقيب على جثث الجنود القتلى فالعثور
على جثه الجنود المتوفره في الحرب يساعد
في التعرف على مصير الالاف من المفقودين
مجموعه من المتطوعين الاوكران تكفلوا بهذه
المهمه الانسانيه في مناطق مختلفه من
اوكرانيا وينتمي جميع الجثث المتطوعون الى
مجموعه تسمي نفسها بلاك توليب وتضم هذه
المجموعه حوالي عشره متطوعين هذه المجموعه
هي واحده من عده مجموعات بالاضافه الى
الوحدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه التي تجوب
مناطق القتال بحثا عن الجثث يقولون انهم
اكتشفوا جثه
311 جنديه روسيا في مناطق متفرقه منذ
فبراير
لكن لماذا جثث الجنود الروس بالتحديد
المجموعه الاوكرانيه تهدف بشكل اساسي الى
جمع تلك الجثث لتمكين الجيش الاوكراني من
تبادلها فيما بعد مع الجانب الروسي وتتم
عمليه التبادل على الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه او على خط المواجهه تحت اشراف
السلطات العسكريه في البلدين وبحضور
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر وتبقى عمليه
التعرف على هويه الجنود المتوفين عمليه
اساسيه لاحصاء عدد ضحايا الحرب ويزعم
اعضاء هذه المجموعه الاوكرانيه المتطوعه
ان الجيش الروسي يعمد الى احراق جثث بعض
جنوده المتوفين وذلك بغيه التقليل من حجم
خسائره في الحرب
[موسيقى]
تصوير قطار الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
قد يضعك على حافه خطر حقيقي الكلام هنا
منقول عن مصور هاون وجد نفسه مضطرا للهروب
من روسيا لتجرئه على تصوير وعرض صور قطار
في اكثر بمناسبه يتعلق الامر بميخائيل
الذي لا يزال يتذكر جيدا القطار
الذي يستخدمه بوتين بعدما ظل يلاحقه
لسنوات سعيا لالتقاط صور له بروتوكوف كان
اول من ينشر صورا لقطار الرئيس وكان ذلك
عام 2018 قبل ثلاثه اعوام من اطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اعجابه بالقطار دفعه الى حد القول ان
البشر العاديين لا يسافرون في مثل هذا
القطار
المصور الهاوي ظل يطارد قطار الرئيس بوتين
لسنوات طويله في بنسبه له كان العثور على
القطار وتصويره انجازا في حد ذاته وحسب
المصور الروسي فان القطار كان مطليا
بلونين الاحمر والرمادي وكان اشبه بقطار
اشباح حيث ان جدوله الزمني كان سريا كما
لا توجد ارقام محدده لقاطراته فضلا عن ان
نوافذه مراقبه بشكل دائم كما ان جميع
القطارات المجدوله الاخرى تفسح المجال
للقطار الرئيس اثناء مروره وتحتوي احدى
عرباته على قبه غير عاديه في الاعلى تضم
على الارجح معدات اتصال خاصه ونقلا عن
مصادر لصحيفه واشنطن
استخدم القطار بشكل متزايد منذ عام 20 21
لصعوبه تتبعه
مثل الطائرات
المصور الهاوي كره تلقى في مايو سنه 2021
رسائل تظهر المحادثات التي كانت تدور بينه
وبين مراقبي القطارات الذين كانوا
يساعدونه في تحديد موقع قطار حينها اكتشف
انه مراقب من طرف جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
وبان الرسائل التي وصلته كانت مجرد تحذير
بنسبه له بعدها قررت توقف عنه روايته
بملاحقه وتصوير قطار الرئيس وقرر الهرب
خارج البلاد خوفا من سجنه واعتقاله وفعلا
غادر
الماضيه حيث توجه بدايه نحو كازاخستان ثم
الهند والان هو هارب في سيراليك
ايضا تتابعون في اخبار الساعه
اختفاء اثنين ونصف طن من اليورانيوم في
ليبي
[موسيقى]
ا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الاخبار الصحه بحث
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
والمنطقه وقالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
على تويتر فيصل
تبادل ايضا واجهات النظر تجاه القضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشت
رك وصف وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
في التوصل لاتفاق بين السعوديه وايران
بالامر الجيد فقال لينك لصحفيين خلال
زيارته لاثيوبيا ان الولايات المتحده ترحب
على او ترحب باي خطوه تساعد في تقليل
التوترات وتجنب الصراع وتردي اي تصرفات او
تردع اي تصرفات خطيره
للاستقرار من جانب ايران
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه علي رضا
عنايه قال اين اللقاء المرتقب بين وزير
الخارجيه حسين امير عبد الله ونظيره
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان سيبحث
تفاصيل عوده سفيري البلدي واضاف عنايه انه
تم فحث مكان الاجتماع بين الوزيرين لكن
هناك حاجه للمزيد من التوافقات بهذا الشان
وتحديد ما اذا كان هناك طرف ثالث ام لا
حسب تعبيره
من جهه اطالبه وسيط طلوبه من المتحده في
اليمن الاطراف المتحاربه بما اسماه انتهاز
فرصه استهداف العلاقات السياسيه بين
السعوديه وايران لاتخاذ خطوه نحو السلام
فقال هانسى جرادنبر ان هناك جهودا
دبلوماسيه مكثفه تجري على مستويات مختلفه
لانهاء الصراع في اليمن مضيفا ان هناك
زخما دبلوماسيا اقليميا متجددا بالاضافه
الى تغيير كبير في نطاق وعمق المناقشات
[موسيقى]
ايضا في اخبار الساعه قال الممثل الامريكي
الخاصه لافغانستان توماس لقناه نيوز
الافغانيه انه على الرغم من ان طالبان
التزمت بعدم استضافه المتطرفين الذين
يرغبون في الحاق الاذى لدول اخرى وعدم
السماح بالتدريب او التجديد او جمع
الاموال في اراضيها فان كل ذلك يحدث
بالفعل كما اكد مسرور امريكيون بان
الجماعات المتطرفه المتمركزه في افغانستان
خططت ونفذت هجمات ضد باكستان وطاجيكستان
واوزبكستان هناك اكثر من 20 جماعه مسلحه
في افغانستان وحدها وبما يثير القلق بشكل
خاص الوجود النشط في افغانستان لحركه
طالبان باكستان وهي جماعه متمرده اعلنت
مسؤوليه عن هجمات ارهابيه عده بباكستان
خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه وفقا لشبكه
فويس
منذ ثلاثه عقود والقلق ما زال يسود
الولايات المتحده بشان وجود مقاتلي
القاعده وقادتها بافغانستان
انخرطت الولايات المتحده في افغانستان بعد
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر للبحث عن قاده
القاعده في اطول حرب خارجيه في تاريخ
امريكا في عام 2022 قتل زعيم القاعده ايمن
الظواهري في كابول في غاره امريكيه بطائره
مسيره وهو امر رفضته طالبان بان الظواهري
قتل في كابول مسؤولون امريكيون يقولون ان
زعيم القاعده الجديد سيف العدل وهو ضابط
سابق في القوات الخاصه المصريه يتواجد في
ايران وسط نافيين من طهران
ونبقى في افغانستان ورغبه ان قانون ارتداء
الحجاب كان المحرك الاساسي هذه المره في
ايران لاطلاق شراره الاحتجاجات ما زالت
هناك اصوات تتعارى داخل السلطات الايرانيه
داعيه الى فرض قيود اضافيه بخصوص الحجاب
في ايران هذا وبات المتشددون في البرلمان
الايراني يبحثون عن سن قوانين جديده
للحجاب الاجباري تتضمن عقوبات اضافيه ومن
بين العقوبات التي ستتضمنها خطه البرلمان
الجديده حجب الخط الهاتفي والانترنت بنسبه
للسيدات اللواتي لا يحترمن قانون الحجاب
النظام الايراني واصل الضغط على المواطنين
والنشاطات والفنانين الداعمين للاحتجاجات
وبهذا الخصوص تداول نشطاء على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تعميما يحضر التعامل مع
53 شخصا من بينهم فنانون تعاطفوا بشكل
واضح مع المتظاهرين ونشر مهدي براحي وهو
مطرب ايد الاحتجاجات صوره لجزء من هذا
التعميم على حسابه على انستجرام وعلق
عليها بالقول انا راض عن جريمته وعشر موقع
ايران انترناشونال الى ان النظام كان قد
مارس ضغوطا كثيره على العديد من المشاهير
من خلال اعتقالهم واستدعائهم وسجنهم
ومنعهم من العمل بسبب دعمهم للمظاهرات
[موسيقى]
اريد ان اخبركم بشيء من القلب في هذه
الاسابيع قابلت الاف المواطنين افضل
مواطني البلد وطنيين حقيقيين من جميع
جوانب النزاع في اسوا كوابيس لم اكن اعتقد
انني ساسمع كلمات من هذه القبيل كلمات
مخيفه حقا يقول البعض من يعتقد ان حربا
حقيقيه بين الاشقاء هي حد لن نصل اليه لا
يعرف شيئا
جانوره هل تصريحات الرئيس الاسرائيلي في
مكانها ام انها فقط محاوله لنزع فتيل
الازمه هل هناك مخاوف حقيقيه من الدلاع
حرب اهليه في اسرائيل
مشاهير رئيس الدوله لم تتكلم بالنجاح مساء
اليوم في هدوء رفض الاحزاب الائتلاف وخاصه
موقف رئيس الحكومه ان نتنياهو الذي رفض
هذا المقترح مقترح رئيس الدوله والذي وصفه
بانه احادي الجانب ولا يحقق الامال ولا
يحافظ على التوازن بين
السلطات المختلفه ولذلك ارى بان هذا الرد
اسد للستار على مساعي رئيس الدوله وان في
ضوء مواقف الائتلاف من جهه والتي ستواصل
مراحل التشريع وموقف المعارضه الذي يشترط
اي تقدم واي وفاق بوقت عمليه التشريع
وايضا قاده المظاهرات الذين يرون
بالمخطط رئيس الدوله لا يجدي وانهم قرروا
بالمواصله في المظاهرات بل لتصعدها اعتقد
بانه اصدر الستاره على هذه المشاعر ونحن
نقترب من تلميحات رئيس الدوله بخطر حرب
اهليه اي ناقوس الخطر قد كرها مساء اليوم
وهو بمثابه خطر القريب جدا طب وهذه نقطه
مهمه اذا المسار الرئيس فشلت
فيما يتعلق بالتوفيق ما بين صلاحيات
السلطات الثلاث ولكن ما المعالم التي دفعت
رئيس الاسرائيلي الى هذه المخاوف هل هناك
اشياء على الارض تدفع بالفعل الى التحذير
من قيام حربه هلاي اهليه في اسرائيل
لاول مره في تاريخ اسرائيل لنرى المظاهرات
التي تعم البلاد للاسبوع الحادي عشر وهي
مظاهرات اللامة
تقتصر على التيارات السياسيه بل ايضا شملت
النقابات واعتقد بان الظاهره الاقصر هي
قيام وحدات من الجيش من من الاحتياط
باتخاذ مواقف ضد
الثوره الفضائيه او الاصلاح الفضائي وهم
يعربون بذلك تذمرهم من قرار
الحكومه الحاليه وخوفهم من تغيير الهيكل
الاساسي لدوله اسرائيل كدوله ديمقراطيه
ومن هنا هذا هو المقصد ايضا اقوال
والتلميح واشاره رئيس الدوله بصوره واضحه
مساء اليوم الى عزل
القوات الجيش الاسرائيلي وعدم المحامها في
الصراع السياسي اعتقد بان هذه هي ايضا من
معالم هذا الصراع الذي تشهده اسرائيل في
هذه الايام
السياسي الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
مشان اخر على الجيش الاسرائيلي والشفاك
والشرطه عن انفجار عبوه الناسفه في منطقه
شمال اسرائيل مطلع هذا الاسبوع اصبرت عن
اصابه اسرائيلي وقال البيان المشترك
للجهات الامنيه ثلاث انه تم تحديد منفذ
الهجوم في مستوطنه عاره مشيرا الى انه كان
في سياره وتم قتله والعثور على اسلحه
وحزام ناسخ بحوزته وحسب تحقيقات
الاسرائيليه فقد تسلل المنفذ من الاراضي
اللبنانيه وانه لا يزال يجري تحقيق موسع
حول العمليه وعن مدى تورطي حزب الله فيها
الى ذلك اكدت مصادر خاصه للعربيه انه يتم
التحقيق في تسلل منفذين اثنين للهجوم عبر
نفق تحت الارض يتبع لحزب الله واضافت
المصادر الى العربيه ان المنفذين
فلسطينيات قتل الجيش الاسرائيلي احدهما
ونجح الاخر في العوده الى لبنان واضافت
مصادر العربيه ان اسرائيل لم تكشف النفق
لفتره طويله وانه ربما تم استخدامه لعمليه
تهريب او دخول منفرديه هجمات
بعد ان وصل وفد القضائي الاوروبي لاستجواب
حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه الى قصر العدل
في بيروت لم يكتمل نصاب الجلسه المقرره
لان سلام لم يحضرها الامر الذي استدعى
تاجيلها الى الخميس القادم في اطار
تحقيقات تتمحور حول ثروته وشبهات غسل
اموال
نا
يتذمر اللبنانيون من ازمه اقتصاديه هي
الاسوا في تاريخ البلاد حلت عليهم في 2019
صنفها البنك الدولي من بين الاسوا منذ عام
1850 وبينما يغص لبنان بازمه سيوله حاده
تبرز قضيه النصف مليار دولار ونعني بها
قضيه الرياض سلامه حاكم المصرف المركزي
المتهم بالتورط في جرائم رشوه وغسل اموال
واختلاس وتهريب وفي كل مره تتحرك القضيه
ينفي سلامه الادعاءات قائلا انها محاوله
لجعله كبش فداء بسبب الازمه الماليه في
لبنان ومن هذه البوابه كان من المقرر ان
يدخل جلسه تحقيق اوروبيه لكنه تغيب عنها
وعليه ارجات السلطات القضائيه الموعد
للخميس لكن وزاره العدل طالبت بالقبض على
حاكم المصرف المركزي وشقيقه رجا مساعدته
مريم الحويك وحجز املاكهم خمس دول اوروبيه
على الاقل وبقائمه تضم 100 سؤال على ثلاثه
ايام سيتولى طرحها قاضي التحقيق الاول في
بيروت شربل ابو سمره وتركز التحقيقات
الاخيره على العلاقه بين مصرف لبنان وشركه
مسجله في الجزر العذراء يعتقد انها لعبت
دور الوسيط لشراء سندات خزينه عبر تلقي
عموله اكتتاب جرى تحويلها الى حسابات
الرجا سلامه في الخارج وقبل عام اعلنت
وحده التعاون القضائي الاوروبيه ان فرنسا
والمانيا و لوكسمبورغ جمدت 120 مليون يورو
من الاصول اللبنانيه اثر تحقيق استهدف
سلامه واربعه من المقربين منه بتهم غسل
اموال بقيمه اكثر من 330 مليون دولار
وخمسه ملايين يورو على التوالي بين 2002
و21
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
اختفاء عشر اسطوانات تحوي نحو اثنين ونصف
من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع في ليبيا
به تركيزات لليورانيوم الخام اوضحت
الوكاله الذريه في بيانها ان ذلك الموقع
لا يخضع حاليا لسيطره الهيئه النوويه
الليبيه ولا الفحص وكان مقررا فحصه العام
الماضي لكنه لكن ذلك تجال لاسباب الامنيه
الوكاله الاكدت انها ستجري مزيدا من
اجراءات التحقق لاصطلاح ملابسات ازاله هذه
المواد وموقعها الحالي وكان حضرت من ان
عدم معرفه مكان هذه المواد ربما يشكل خطرا
اشعاعيا ويثير كذلك مخاوف تتعلق بالامن
النووي
ايضا في اخبار الساعه
تحقيق فيدرالي في احتمال وجود غسيل اموال
في شركه ترامب للاعلان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد يثير مشروع قانون الهجره
الجديد الذي تسعى فرنسا الى تطبيقه جدلا
واسعا حيث سيسمح بمنح الاقامه في فرنسا
للموظفين في مجال الصحه من اجل استقطاب
الاطباء الى جانب لتلبيه الحاجه الى
التوظيفات الى التوظيف في مستشفيات
الطبيب
المخيف ضد
النساء مستقبله المهني في فرنسا منذ وصوله
اليها لاكمال دراسته فقرر البقاء كحال
الكثير من الكفاءات الطبيه من اصول
المغاربيه التي تستقطبها فرنسا بشكل دائم
هدفكور منحني شوي ونرجع لتونس هذا الهدف
الاساسي بعدين عشت هون يعني سنه بالنسبه
للستاجل يعني التربس اللي عملته وشفت
الفرقه الواسع الكبير ونحكي على مجال الطب
يعني ظروف العمل المشهيه ذاتها ظروف حتى
العلميه
مش هي ذاتها يعني هون الظروف احسن المشكله
مش في فرنسا ولا في السياسه فرنسا ولا في
المشكل في البلد اللي انت فيه يعني اذا
كان انت بلدك موفر لكل الظروف ولكن اذا
بلدك موفر لك ظروف العمل وظروف العلم
وظروف التطور ابدا مش راح تفكر تطلع
وبينما تسعى الحكومه الفرنسيه الى تعزيز
قطاعها الصحي من خلال تسهيل قدوم الاطباء
الاجانب عبر منحهم بطاقه اقامه خاصه بهم
وذلك عبر سن مشروع قانون الهجره الجديد
تزداد مخاوف الدول مغاربيه وافريقيا
الفرانكفونيه التي تزود المستشفيات
الفرنسيه عاده بالعاملين في القطاع الصحي
من عمليه افراغ مؤسساتها الطبيه من
الاطباء
منذ سنوات اصبح النظام الصحي الفرنسي في
حاله توتر وبات الوصول الى الرعايه الصحيه
يتدهور تدريجيا بسبب عدم وجود عدد كافي من
العامل النفيع هناك ضروره للزياده عدد
قبول الاطباء
فرنسا ليست البلد الوحيد الذي يستقطب
الكفاءات العلميه من تلك الدول اذ تشمل
هذه الظاهره بقيه الدول الغربيه الا ان
هذا المشروع قد يسبب هجره جماعيه لاطباء
الدول المغاربيه من سيؤدي الى تقليص فرص
سكانها في الحصول على العلاج
قطه الحكومه
الفرنسيه قانون الهجره الجديد قد تعود
بالفائده على فرنسا لحل ازمه نقص الاطباء
لكنها قد تسبب ذات الازمه في البلدان الام
خاصه في المناطق التي تعاني فقرا في اليد
العامله بالقطاع الصحي زينه عادي العربيه
باريس
اكد وزير الخساره البريطاني ان بلاده
ستتجنب حاله ركود هذا العام خلافه لتوقعات
سابقه مؤكدا الدعم الميزانيه ميزانيه
الدفاع في 11 مليار جنيه استرلي
ب اؤكد اننا سنضيف ما مجموعه 11 مليار
جنيه استرليني الى ميزانيه دفاعنا على مدى
السنوات الخمس المقبله وستكون تقريبا
اثنين وربع بالمئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2025 نحن كنا اول دوله
اوروبيه تلتزم بنسبه 2% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للدفاع وسنقوم الان برفع ذلك الى
2.5% بمجرد ان تسمح لنا الظروف الماليه
والاقتصاديه بذلك
[موسيقى]
بدا المدعون العامون الفيدراليون في
نيويورك فحصا ما اذا كانت شركه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي التابعه
تنتهكانين غسيل الاموال حسب الجاردن يجري
التحقيق في قبول شركه ترامب للاعلام
لثمانيه ملايين دولار من الاموال الروسيه
المشبوهه ويبحث المدعون الفيدراليون في
تحويل الاموال لشركه ترامب من بنوك في
منطقه الكاريبي من كيانات غامضه يبدو انها
تخضع لسيطره احد الاثرياء الروس المقربين
من بوتين
تسببت الفيضانات التي ضربت جنوب تركيا
بمقتل عده اشخاص اضافه لفقدان اخرين ما
زالت السلطات تبحث عنهم حيث شهدت المنطقه
التي ضربها زلزال هطولا مطريا كبيرا خلال
الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه
بعد الزلزال فيضانات تضرب مناطق بج
نوب الفيضانات ضربت ولايه
المعلومات تؤكد وقوع قتل السوريين واتراك
بينهم اطفال
كميات الامطار التي هطلت على الولايتين
تراوحت بين 111 الى 136 ملم في المتر مربع
بعض الصور اظهرت السيوله تجري ف اناسا
وسيارات في الولايتين
ابرزها انقاذ طفله وامراه في اللحظات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
في الختام تذكير بابرز العالم
لا تسافر كافه اجهزتها للوصول الى حطام
المسيره في البحر الاسود بعد اعلان موسكو
البحث عنها
بعد سجناء الرجال موسكو تجند السجينات
الروسيات للحرب في جبهات القتال شرق
اوكرانيا
رغم تعهداتها السابقه طالبان تؤوي اكثر من
عشرين جماعه مسلحه في افغانستان نفذت
هجمات في دول العده
وبعد مظاهرات مستمره الرئيس الاسرائيلي
يحذر من حرب اهليه بسبب خطه الحكومه
لاحكام يدها على القطع
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]